that's right so we do see a repeat of
the opening from the first game
we mentioned it a couple of times the
opening is called the grunfeld defense
this normally signifies that black is
happy to let white have the center but
black is going to counter-attack and we
see early on if we bring up the analysis
board black has brought his queen into
the game very very early we don't
normally want to do this at home because
the queen will get attacked we saw in
this position white has white has the
center white controls the center
therefore black needs to play fast you
can't let your opponent control the
midfield you the center of the board um
you need to counter-attack therefore
black gave a check this is a check to
the king white block this check there's
three ways of dealing with the check you
either have to run away with your king
you have to block or you have to capture
the attacking piece
this time white chose to block attacking
the white queen and the queen enters the
white camp this is very controversial
i've actually studied this position
myself i prefer white
black's queen it looks very nice in the
white camp but later it will get kicked
about it will get attacked by white's
bishop or it will get attacked by
white's rook yeah this is very much
still opening preparation and now magnus
is the one who has to recall his
preparation is like i completely agree
it's all about practice whether that's
playing through things on the board i
personally learn from the heat of battle
i like to play games the feeling the in
like the intimacy of that battle
it's that feeling which really kind of
spurs me on
and magnus did remember he made a move
and janan pugnacci answered uh what uh
what's happening on the board now
we could
we think the game is about to end
actually
yeah um prematurely with a repetition of
moves we'll talk about space repetition
to repeating things to remember but this
time um janna pomnyacci he has the
option to repeat the position for a
third time but it hadn't he got slightly
confused about this the placement of one
okay
and we have that move we have a move it
is a queen check it's not the same queen
check that we saw earlier so it's a
slightly different position but it all
depends if magnus castle blocks with his
bishop the probably actually he's got to
decide where to put his queen out if he
puts it back from where it came from oh
he's changed his mind he's made a
different move okay
yes we're gonna have so we will have a
fight yes yes
he he was really angry and we're not wow
yeah something
something really upset him and we're not
quite sure what it is we will definitely
try to get an interview after all the
games they have finished and ask him
about that okay we do have some moves
that's right so white has actually
sacrificed a pawn we see that one of
white's pawns there on the left side has
disappeared from the board black's queen
is gone on an adventure she's been
greedy she's grabbed a pawn there
and we see that black actually those
pawns on the left side um black's pawns
at the top of the board they are
unrivalled they are unmatched those
pawns later will be a huge factor trying
to rush down the board this is the game
for him he needs to fight
he needs to come back in this game
otherwise he might not get another
chance impressive just to kind of do 20
moves like that but it is very much like
you've played at the hand and knows what
it wants to do um there are other kind
of situations which are so unusual that
five moves in um i think that's the case
for napoli actually here who's had this
position before but magnus carlsen may
be less familiar he doesn't have that
muscle memory in this exact position
that's why he's spent so much time on
that yeah i think i was told that it
took someone three months to fully
memorize one opening that's right so
maybe if we bring up the analysis board
we can explain magnus carlsen's last
move especially surprises me a bit um we
see that white's bishop has just
moved um whoops sorry um white bishop
has just moved up the board two two
squares um he wants to support his
central pawns so white his whole idea is
to push in the center meanwhile we see
it's a race normally we see pawn races
in the end game but here we see a race
already it's getting exciting what black
is pushing and look at the bar the bar
is zooming up in black's direction this
pawn um this pawn on the left side it's
already only three squares from making a
new queen meanwhile white is pushing in
the center white pawn is also three
squares from making a new queen it's a
race which pawn is stronger on the left
the pawn on the left flank or the pawn
in the center um black
retreats his queen out of the way this
pawn this pawn is nearly running home
already white just pushes his queen
forward it's a wrath
one step further so this is such an
intriguing battle because one of the
great things about having a pawn like
that on the edge of the board is that
equal
decoy a lot of white's pieces and i just
really like what magnus is doing he's
just calmly centralizing his rooks so
attacking the queen and he's going
magnus is going to try to use all his
pieces to support the advance of that
his pawn in the center flank was so far
down the board already so close to
making a new queen
you can see the queen is now supporting
that pawn so that pawn is really ready
to march one square forward and then
make a queen so magnus has to tread
carefully is looking a little bit worse
yeah on he's looking worse on the board
and also maybe affected by that
disconnection earlier those internet
issues um his time situation he has only
four minutes in a bad position um there
we see he shuffled his rook across to
the corner his rook has come back from
where it came from his rook started on
that square but it has to stop the black
pawn he's targeting that pawn right now
it is that black pawn is defended by the
black queen and the black rook behind it
sooner or later we will see another
black pawn start to race down the board
first he develops a bishop yeah that's
very nicely done the bishop comes in to
help the game the only the only
reason he would be allowed to if if he
had
agreed with the arbiter that he was
allowed to
that's right i think magnus carson he's
not the kind who would complain about
that he wouldn't launch an appeal it
must have come down to the arbiter's
decision i think that pawn uh that we
see it's at home now it's on the the b
line um it is gonna start running okay
it doesn't yet napoli actually tries to
trade a pair of rooks i'm less keen on
that one but i think napoleon she's
still in complete control
and apparently apparently he was allowed
to leave the room he had gotten
permission from the arbiter so he is
not in any way um
cheating or not in any way um
disqualified excellent yes good news
excellent good news because we really
don't want to be losing a game like that
exactly so all right well there has been
so much drama in this game both chess
wise and um other things happening but
now they are playing and yana pomnyacci
what's happening
that's right and um black is offering a
trade of queens right now
i think ivanka you didn't like that last
move by white retreating a bishop to the
back line you don't want to retreat
unless there's a clear reason magnus
carson attacking his opponent's queen we
see magnus there just gesturing against
the camera he's so frustrated right now
everything's turned against him in this
game his internet connection the
position the clock
we see the queens have left the board
black is still a pawn ahead though and
it's an important pawn it's that pawn on
the left flank that huge
really advanced pawn there for black
that is going to decide the game yeah
white force to retreat another bishop
black's rook now lines itself up with
those two bishops those two white
bishops under fire from the white uh
from the black rook
black's in complete control we see that
by the bar as well a four-point
advantage here for black it looks like
he's leaving his pawn here this very
advanced this powerful pawn unprotected
the problem is white's rook cannot move
it is tied down to this bishop wrecking
my brains because you've got to find
moves that are tricky as well and magnus
carlsen has found the best move i think
just to advance his bishop and attack
that all-important dangerous pawn white
is just running out of uh running out of
resources all of his pawns okay we see a
pawn has left the board
and he's running out of time as well
he is running out of time and uh the
position is not looking so hot okay so
magnus has moved his bishop to attack
the rook and the rook has moved to
counter-attack the bishop that white has
on the dark squares um we could see a
trade of bishops here this last move
very clever from magnus uh from
nyanapolici it looked like he was about
to drop some points here drop some
material instead his rook just steps
back counter-attack now two bishops are
looking at each other as well we've seen
magnus carson capture this pawn
but i think black can just simply trade
bishops on this square and then capture
upon with his other bishop black's
bishops in complete control black is
also going to be a couple of pawns ahead
magnus trying to stay in this game just
trying to survive as long as possible we
saw him save a losing position in the
last game but if napoleon is careful if
he's accurate then it is easier the
margin for a draw becomes lower and
lower for magnus carlsen no completely
agreed he's going to be two pawns ahead
um i think now is the important moment
he needs to okay he finds it he captures
a pawn in the center with his bishop
white finally removes that far advanced
pawn on the left flank there
but if we count the material left black
is two pawns ahead two pawns in the end
game is normally a decisive advantage
but black has an extra pawn on both the
right hand side and the left side um
black now just bringing his king into
the position his advantage dropping
slightly there i think he had a stronger
move but black is still in charge
and he has gone under five and even four
minutes on the clock kiana pognashi you
have said that is when the clocks start
ringing and it starts to get very tense
jana ponnyacci is thinking about his
next move it is a pawn move
and he has marched that that pawn
forward on the left-hand side of the
board it is going to inch ever closer to
making himself a queen the bishops have
come off and i do expect i think white
needs to make sure that his rook is on a
more active square at the moment it's
not great he needs to keep an eye on
that black pawn on the left side there
and normally rooks they belong behind
pawns especially past pawns which have
no arrival
i think this is the best way to stop
black spawn if you leave it one move if
you move your okay he puts his rook in
front instead his rook is passively
placed in front we see the engine
stuckfish doesn't like that move at all
that might be the losing mistake from
magnus carson his final chance was to
put his rook behind instead of in front
of the pawn no way
exactly along the same lines as you
david the rook's behind the pawn and now
it's in front because it's passive
because if you're ever going to save an
end game like this when your material
down it's by having a really good rook
and if your rook is behind was in front
of that pawn well it's not very good
it's not very active and this is boring
that's right and there was a trap in
that position magnus carson couldn't
have taken that pawn with his rook
because if the rooks get traded off the
board black will win
absolutely kyle that's what i think as
well i really love what napoleonic is
doing he is going to be using teamwork i
mean david said it earlier on teamwork
makes the dream work and that is
that is so super important in an aim
game so i fully expect to see
that king the black king start marching
its way to the left-hand side of the
board the left-hand side of the board
and if i lose one pawn am i going to be
in time and this is the problem okay so
actually we've seen that happen okay
has made a run for it with the king and
that king is going to be headed towards
the left-hand side of the board to
assist that pawn in promoting if white
would have to resign or give up
immediately if white captured the spawn
with his rook black could finish the
game immediately by trading off the
rooks
this rook is now pinned we would say
white's rook cannot move because the
king is behind it the rooks would have
to leave the board and once the rooks
leave the board black is a pawn ahead
when you're a pawn ahead in king and
pawn end games you are winning this pawn
is just going to run home or distract
the white king also if white had
captured the pawn with his king the same
thing would happen black would drop the
rook down and the rooks would trade uh
be exchanged leaving the board and black
would win therefore magnus carson
doesn't take that pawn he doesn't fall
into the trap he gives a check
napoleon actually tries to trade rooks
um but we see that magnus he he just has
to keep the rooks he has to hope for the
best now i think he just has to pray
um napoleon actually defending his pawn
with his rook there
yeah two extra pawns in rook and rook
and games is normally uh enough to win
and magnus retreating with his rook
i think napoli actually he just needs to
bring his king left he's not rushing yet
he's just advancing his pawns on the
right side i i think there's no reason
not to bring his king to the left side
right now
that being said he's not rushing that's
a good thing that is a good thing
because there's a little motto which
says uh
hurry
hurry don't rush to maintain a winning
advantage um he doesn't find it oh
no
i'm not liking this move at all
and stockfish doesn't like that move
magnus carson was frowning as well but
magnus carson maybe not finding the best
reply giving the advantage back to black
um we we saw that white's now white rook
is shuffling across one square he's
trying to jump up the board and give
check with his rook he wants to attack
the black king but i think he had a
safer option he could have just kept
that pawn blockaded black's pawns on the
right side now he's advanced them they
look good but they're actually weak so i
think the pontiac's last few moves the
plan wasn't great he should have rushed
his king over to the left side napoli
actually was winning it also has a past
pawn in the equation oh okay so black
has centralized the rook and napoli
actually
okay actually magnus carson pushes his
rook all up all the way up the wood i
was gonna say napoleon actually looking
calm just taking a sip of water there
finally magnus carlsen we talked about
rooks needing to be behind pawns in
black's pawns but maybe it's too late
now black is the one
pushing his rook forward to attack
white's pawns that pawn on the beeline
um once that pawn disappears
oh the computer hates that move the bar
says now it's a draw what's happening oh
look at that and i look at that magnus
doesn't even capture the pawn instead he
gives a little check to drive the king
backwards oh and i think
i think napolita's blown it he has blown
at this position um
napole he will still win one of white's
pawns there white's remaining poor
napoleon actually probably will win that
one but this position is actually a
well-known draw black will be two pawns
ahead but those two pawns they're not
connected they're not connected to each
other they're separated this one it is a
draw but white needs to know what he's
doing all right and magnus is now
thinking
and he makes this move is he doing the
right move here that's right he's going
behind with his rook now to try and
check that black king um finally magnus
carson he's got a position that he will
have studied before i can guarantee
magnus carlsen studied this exact ending
before with black having two extra pawns
but separated pawns um basically all he
needs to do is make sure those pawns
don't advance together and they're very
they're very dangerous when those pawns
are far advanced up the board porn that
is in white's half of the board is very
well guarded by the king and i know i
think magnus has this completely under
control
what
unbelievable stuff to be honest i i've
said it before today and it's just not
your napoleon to this day
that's right
looking down
everything was in his favor as well
magnus got disconnected magnus was
flustered he couldn't focus he was just
angry with the position bad i mean bad
situation on the clock bad situation on
the board
he just let it be traded off he's left
himself with two pawns but white's king
will easily deal with those pawns
um yeah this is very very surprising
stuff napoli actually he will be able to
advance another pawn here we see him
push upon the problem is now there's
just no way of making progress he has to
give up one pawn to get the other one
running but one pawn in a rook in game
is not enough the rook needs to mobilize
itself but okay then brook has made
blessings okay and magnus will take off
that pawn and now
okay so we are going to see a lovely
technique by magnus carlsen so i suspect
that his rook will now get excellent
shots and uh he hasn't been able to put
the ball
in the net
that's right twice in a row um and we
see magnus castle just repeating the
position there he's going to use his
rook to start checking the black king
sooner or later um this is a very well
known draw black only has one pawn left
and that pawn will not be allowed to
advance the whole way white's just going
to keep giving checks
sometimes he can even offer to trade
rooks white now because one pawn on its
own isn't enough so an opponent is
trying hard by advancing this king but
notice how magnus carlsen is using his
king and his rook to stop that pawn
advancing remember in end games it is
david howell's favorite expression
teamwork makes a dream work and you have
to remember that
that's right and both whites rook and
and king covering the same square
covering the pawn advance napoli
actually they're just shuffling his rook
across that move actually doesn't do
anything it's a waiting move and now the
rook ha the white rook has come to
gobble up the white pawn and we are
going to see
i think the players agree a very quick
draw that's right napoli actually you
can tell on his face he knows it's over
he's laughing to himself he's missed
another opportunity
second game in a row he had it in the
bag just
nerves the clock everything just made
him yeah absolutely